[Music]
one
this is casey wilson on the show today
casey
is easily the closest person to me
spiritually not geographically no no no
but we
casey wilson you've seen her on a little
show called happy endings
which every time someone uh comes up to
me to talk about two bro girls or
that um well-received nbc sitcom i did
um they go you know what show is good
happy endings it's all it's always like
oh yeah you did that have you seen happy
endings like
every single time i remember when that
audition came around
and it was like your husband you have
now married
the creator of the show yes of course so
i stayed slept my way lower middle
yep i remember the day uh i knew you
guys were going to be together really
yes why what happened because we were at
a bar
on santa monica in hollywood silverspoon
now connie and ted yes i wrote
uh every script that did not go at
uh silverspoon i sat there and i was
like i'm gonna make it i'm gonna make i
wrote
i wrote a movie there where a guy
pretended to have cancer to get a girl
to like him
it was a it was a good it was a flim
yeah it was a flimsy if there was
something there
it was more of a tweet so many of the
projects that were going for five years
i'm like that was a tweet yeah like i
really kind of feel like that was a cool
short instagram if anything in the tweet
it's like something you scroll by real
quick it doesn't even
hold captioning you were wearing i once
one thing i really will say about
casey someone who has created shows
written movies
uh ass backwards is truly brilliant with
june
she uh uh gets every job that i want and
frankly that's true frankly i agree with
i agree with them because the world has
said yes to you on a larger plane
so with me they're like yeah well you
can do the trickle-down parts because
we've given you like a headlining role
no one says yes this has been completely
non-consensual
on the behalf of hollywood you have been
the threat
for training oh you'd want to hire me
all right well i can just go on facebook
right now and say you molested me so you
inter
yeah you've been very threatening um
the thing you do about write books i was
dying on the plane at the wreckage of my
presence her new book
there's nothing mother of two boys
married i don't spend much time with
them the thing you do the best if i
uh if i may is wear cut off jean shorts
you were wearing cut off jean shorts to
like the mid thigh
when when you and david were at this
bar you just i'm like i've never worn a
short in my life okay but this
makes sense tonight this makes sense i
was like i'm sorry when did you see me
you were kind of it was like the bottom
half was like a like a pirate costume
you know i've always struggled with
fashion it was so
like i remember watching you and you're
like like flirting with uh this
i mean to us was like a big hollywood
creator like biggest catch in town
and she's in her jean shorts like
there's
no reason he's you know what i mean like
not
not um not trying too hard as i would
say
as we just said earlier yeah yeah yeah a
simple gal just a simple gal
and i just i've always been in uh such
awe of of you and what you've done
because
um you and i met
you take this one okay so we met the
first desperate year i moved out here
and speaking of jean
shorts i would wear actually a tight
little jean skirt and my legs were like
little sausages in them
and it was like cut up to my crack and i
would walk down
sunset to la brea and get in and out
burger and cry and just walk home every
day and then wonder why i wasn't getting
jobs and why
i was overweight and then i decided to
take an acting class
right in that same strip and i met you
in a casting class workshop that was
real do zero
here's what i loved about casey and how
i knew we were instantly going to be
friends
there were two giant like super cozy
like couches
and i walked in i sat on the floor
she walked in sat on the floor i was
like we are the same person
we could sit on this super cozy couch
and we're just going to sit here on the
floor
you know what i'd like to say about
myself is that i would sit on the couch
today and to me that is because i just
demand to be comfortable at all times so
i'm going to say that that's maybe the
only growth i've had
what i have from the floor to the couch
what i will argue is in fact uh you
you would walk in and say this is the
couch where's the bed
yes reading your book you've identified
yourself as a bed person
which i would like to get to yeah but
first i need to take my meds
and so do i so i had brought this as a
gift for
you which is for me to take my
okay this is tough i'm taking this pill
for you yes i was like
this is a gift for all of you actually
it's not just for me
so i'm on two different two different
cocktails okay one is a wellbutrin which
i
do not take for add but apparently if it
helps you with that you can
retroactively diagnose yourself
wonderful got it got it i got it
everybody as soon as they
are on antidepressants or have had covid
they instantly have a medical degree
oh no i know yeah i literally like that
you're on that under depression
i don't know well i mean it's working
based on this conversation
everyone here will be like it's not
working although you're going to see me
get real jazzed up in a second
but the second one is a tougher one to
hear as a diagnosis which
is called my therapist was like we need
to put you on a quote
mood stabilizer stabilize my mood
i think i seem pretty stabilized but
let's see where i can go from here
where the where the rotates are oh let's
get a cheers going no this is uh
yes oh no this is uh lunesta
but what just because i like to roll the
dives every night you're gonna take that
now
no i have i did take a nyquil before i
did
um a talk show once and if you google
real hard you'll be able to
sorry there's a pill in my mouth oh god
tell which one
since i've been traveling just attend
shows in spokane
i was like let me just condense them all
in once oh yeah throw them into one so
now i have my lunesta
and my prozac intransitone in one place
sorry the fact that i haven't tried it
on asleep
trazanone is actually um see i have such
an attic brain i'm looking at those
colors and i'm like
whoo did you see me just put the nest in
my mouth
because you were talking i wasn't paying
attention but see i hate people are like
get a pill case i'm like i don't i put
them all in here i shake them up i like
that yeah
i like for the best i like when um
somebody is uh being
shitty in a meeting or something i'll
kick my purse and i'll fall out and i'll
be like oh sorry
because i'm like oh god it's being too
hard on her
here's what i will say um
can i tell the story is it too
unrelatable about the lexus
i never claim to be relatable though so
i want i'm not sure others have tried to
say that about me and i have bucked
under that label i'm not sure oh by the
way is her podcast
people get mad at me that i don't
introduce the guests on the show
and tell everyone who they're
experiencing half okay just i don't know
if only there was a search engine where
you could find
all the information you needed anytime
you wanted um but i
uh i people might need a few more
credits to please no
which is easily the most beloved
podcast
i can think of well we the bed when
you came on and we're actually
re-releasing your episode as a whole
thing because we tried to split it
because we loved it so much
well come on again i hope have me back i
like a double pop i like a second
round of a guest okay and see we can
always come here and just do you super
quick
i would love or you guys both come on
the podcast yeah we've got things to get
into anyway yeah okay but what is the
lexus story
okay so you know i was always just
driving the shittiest car
i was sharing car with three people and
as our careers rose and you sensed i did
not have a ton of money but i
could possibly afford a car i called it
like 50 000
debt when we met oh yeah yeah yeah
i mean you know i had an assistant as i
say in the book when i was an assistant
so i was always aspirational
no casey casey had this i was very
confusing i was like she's either like
um
a billionaire's daughter or
you know a republican's daughter that's
what it ended up being or
like a poor republican has a delusional
amount of confidence but i don't
in the fact that she's gonna make it yes
and it worked
i mean it was a mental illness that
delusional confidence is a mental
illness like magical thinking until you
actually make it and then you just had
grit
see i have body dysmorphia in the wrong
direction i'm like i look good
and it served me let me let you finish
the lexus story all i was going to say
is that you have always been one step
ahead of the trends with
like everything i want to get to i'll be
like whitney you have to see the psychic
you're like i saw the psychic 10 years
ago
they're actually embroiled in like a me
too scandal whatever it is you've done
it
processed them and spit them out and i'm
now like just paid for 10 packages with
them
that i never see them again the psychic
you sent me to i did put in the book
because the psychic you tempt me to
actually told me i was going to marry
david told me i was going to have two
kids neglected to tell me that my car
had been towed during the session
but i was like you can't have it all
yeah and she was right about all
of it yeah
and here's the thing and i'm not like
like psychics like i know people are
like roll their eyes whatever you did
say something about um
a psychic in the book where you wrote in
parentheses like
the only psychic whose scientists have
studied their brain
and i don't know what that means but she
told me that it's just
it's just something that she told you
that oh right right got it got it got it
so um it's something that you do that is
so
beautiful and sometimes it frustrates me
because i
i'm so desperate for you to see yourself
how i see you and however
everyone else sees you i see myself
pretty well i just mean like
to be like defensive like you got to get
ahead of someone's
judgment yeah turn to me like that's
kind of the key to
i think such a funny book is that
they're reading it alone you can't
answer their question because they're
going a psychic and you go
the only one like oh yeah you're
addressing any
reaction you know that they're having
and it's just like if you feel so seen
you're like oh my gosh
i was just thinking just my base need to
be like which okay i'm sorry just pivot
but you also said somebody
that killed me i've told so many people
this they
died i did something insane you called
me and called my manager and said this
is really bad what you're up to
and it was just quite insane behavior
and i was like i'm really sorry you had
to see all that and you were like
it's totally fine as long as you accept
this as your allen on rock bottom
i'm good with it i thought you were
talking about
the time that when you were planning
your wedding you
uh called all of your single girlfriends
myself included and said hey
i would like to organize a
flash mob during the ceremony
when all of the single attendees
women women okay yes women was shaving
only shaving shaming women only shaping
women specifically
and i was like that's not funny we're
already gonna put them at a singles
table quite far away from the adults
yeah
gonna put them in a singles table with
each other instead of with the same
people who figured out
how to find someone they're the ones who
could set us up
no no you were on your own don't keep us
enabled with this like it's like
cuckoo's nest over here
barely on the lawn we were we were
sorry there was like a beautiful
beautiful dead and then and then we were
like
right in the sunlight so sorry it's
hilarious to me it's the best
i wasn't trying to keep all the single
people together but i did have a very
bad idea for them
which was i was at margaritas with two
friends and i'm thinking like what are
fun ways i can like jazz up my wedding
you know and i always hated that like
when the father and daughter start
dancing like break it down and
everyone's like oh well father and
daughter are like dancing to like kiss
from a rose
so try to do a sketch trying to do a
sketch and i know steve martin and i
doing that
and sorry i'm going all over the place
when i was on snl i did a parody
by did i mean it went to dress rehearsal
not to air um with steve martin where he
played my dad and we were breaking it
down and we found ourselves in a
rehearsal room the choreographer never
showed up
and he's like so what am i doing what
what what are we doing and i'm like
okay how about you get down on all fours
and i'm like i'm like riding you across
the room
we could do it so much break his back
and he's like i cannot do this anymore
i was like i want to kill myself i want
to
jump out of a bat of 30 rock so that was
also in my head and at work of like i
want to make fun of these like
tropes yes to bring us here i thought it
would be funny after two margaritas to
to what to have all my single friends
come up like a flash mob from all
different areas and i'm talking like my
aunt
who's 80 like trickling all the way down
bumping every branch
on the way down to come out and do a
flash mob to single ladies
and if i may her wedding was in like six
months so it basically meant i know
you're the most offensive
i know you're still gonna be single like
i was like ain't no chance
anybody these are not need to replace
anybody these are not only the people
that are currently single
but i assure you they still will be
single
one person am i wondering are they gonna
have to like bail there was a tax chain
got a text that said hey we want to do
this flash thing
there's nothing what we mean there are
very few things
people that i just it's whatever you
want whatever you need
absolutely yeah uh i then get a schedule
of rehearsals
there was like every sunday there was i
had rented out third street dance
um in beverly hills and i thought this
is going to be fun
like this would be funny and but she
said it
as parker posey and dazed and confused
she's yelling at the girls
i'll be with them but like i'm not
single anymore and then it hit me
someone said something and i was like
this is the most horrifying offensive
idea and i cannot believe i've pitched
it to people
and i'm so upset it's really to this day
like antithetical to who i am you know
what
here's my deal is that i'm gonna argue
with you about all the things you think
about yourself okay
in my estimation trying to call you in i
was like
casey doesn't know what she's signing i
get to be the star of her wedding
casey is so good sharing
the screen and that's yeah she's gonna
allow me
to come out shine her her own wedding
like who am i
who am i to stop her yeah
thanks for seeing it that way it wasn't
that way it wasn't meant that way
but yeah you're like no no if you got in
my shot i would just trip you i had it
all
and like i i'm just i really apologize
for that so can we
can i and if you want to go to any other
direction at any point please do
but i want to have nowhere else i had so
many
things going through my head i literally
was um on the plane reading your book
and i wrote an entire i have a lot to
say
you're so sweet i have a lot to say
because i think you and i have spent a
lot of our lives
trying to fix ourselves heal ourselves
you know go to healers go to
most of which we paid by check and went
to their apartment
um i mean we've gone through cash yeah
psychics
stone therapist charcoal colonoscists
i talk about a woman in this book that i
saw and she claimed
that she i thought she was gonna be
cooking lessons but then also she's like
but we're gonna dabble in your food
story as it relates to your generational
trauma
get my head around it but at a certain
point i did want to learn how to make
like a
chicken you know or like do a salad and
she came over
and what transpired in that kitchen my
son is screaming i'm like leaving him
she's charging me a thousand dollars an
hour and like willy nilly ordering
things off liam sonoma just like
you know what you need no metal why do
you have a metal spatula
she's like this is so bad for you i'm
like why we never get to why
she creates a hydration station she
throws out all my stuff
and then she's like everything must be
wood we must cover this metal with all
these blankets
then after i keep being like could i
learn how to make oatmeal like like i
just at any point
i don't i'm not trying to be a martha no
i know i'm in a married world i feed my
kids
you're like my mom was a feminist i'm
trying to kind of tell her i'm like i
just don't know how to make tacos and
she's like we
are so far from tacos right now like she
was like i can't even begin with you and
she goes i wish you'd know me when you
remodeled this kitchen
like okay then when i think we're done
with the
extensive session she's like you need
more work i want you to come to my house
i go to her now i'm in her house in
culver city and she literally charged me
i'm not and i know everyone listening is
this it makes me look terrible but it is
no no
we've all done this part um broken
person she's like you're gonna wander
around my backyard barefoot it was a
dirty backyard
she's like i want you to wander around
for about half hour maybe get on the
swing just really see the space
lie down in the backyard meanwhile i see
her in there just like doing her
and i paying for this i get into her
house she just says just lie down and
then i want you to just make a little
piece of artwork in my dank garage
and charged me fifteen hundred dollars
is her name aunt lydia
this is bananas but i was like when's my
next session
but as that but as that uh as you said
that i
just kept thinking we've all done this
we've all done this it's like in some
way shape or form
whether it was a guy or he you know what
i mean like we've all sort of
my friend tells you go see this person
or that person and we're always thinking
the next person is going to
be the thing but also i think that the
thing
that we actually needed to solve if i'm
going to be honest was the fact that we
thought we needed to be fixed yes that's
what i mean
i'm saying that was the thing so we were
thinking operating from a place of such
lack and such
brokenness that it is so the last
possible solution could have been me
clear that this person is a quack and
i'm just like yes i mean like
like with guys it's just so clear to me
that this person to everyone else
and everyone else is bad for me but like
i will
go along with like a charlatans magical
thing i will go on
whatever because i grew up with a lot of
like alcohol calm a lot of lying like oh
yeah the reason that this broke is
because
you know the clown came like i'd hear
these wild
stories you know what i'm just saying
like the clown came yeah and the clown
stopped by because we had this clown
that was going to come give you a big
party but then the rain hit it and now
he's not here when in reality you just
like
were cheating and mom threw a wine glass
at you i mean
and i'd be like oh my god the clown get
like i am willing to go
a big part which is ironic because i
hate improv
uh but i am willing to go along with
like a terrible
story because i don't i also get
embarrassed for the person
because i just and then i'm like this
might be so crazy it's actually
real like i come full circle with that
but we've been taught to doubt ourselves
and trust you we don't know where the
ground is right and we're just like i'm
so stupid i guess i need to stand around
on a playground and i think when you
grow up with like i'll speak for myself
like some addiction or whatever you're
always
i'm always like guessing at normal i'm
like is what she's doing normal like
the thousands of of moments i've been
like oh that's you need to bring
something someone's house oh that's how
you do that oh that's supposed to be in
your fridge oh that's
so i'm like it just why wouldn't it
outwardly extend to any human who has
any piece of anything to give me i'm
like i just must not know that
or you have accommodated to a way that
works for you
and that's fine i'm saying yeah my new
thing is like oh i have to be normal
like this person and they're like that
person's crazy just because they
show up with a bottle of wine doesn't
mean that they're a sane person
i mean because it's about the motives
like why are you bringing the wine
because you're trying to
like make them like you you're trying to
you know what like it's about the
motives
you know and a lot of people do
ostensibly healthy things with sneaky
motives where they bring you a
bottle of wine or whatever to a dinner
two months later like what you haven't
called me back yet i brought you a
bottle of wine like i thought we were
friends and you're like oh i didn't
realize there were strings attached
so i'm gonna get really um into
the things that we tried to change about
ourselves
okay and how they were actually
superpowers
that we were shamed into or socially
constructed or
whatever into believing were flaws i was
actually just listening to sad but to a
self help book on the way over here
which one uh wayne dyer okay
and i've never as a friend just was like
try this and and
he just said we need to this i know this
is cheesy and people are gonna say
whatever but like just to say to
ourselves like we all belong
like we all belong in this earth yeah
like we wouldn't be here if we didn't
just like we all belong like sometimes
those
simple statements bring you back to
reality like i belong to be here i
deserve to be here
wherever you are yeah because we make
ourselves like so small like i'm on a
show right now with like big actors and
every day i come in and i have to fight
against like i don't deserve to be here
and it's so boring
okay so when you do that like this is my
new thing about that i don't deserve to
be here because i had that for so long
it's like okay
so the casting director is stupid the
director
the director is like a total idiot i
slipped through some crap
they picked me out of a thousand people
so they must be idiots
it's actually kind of an arrogant thing
when you like look back at it
i don't deserve to be here which means
all of these people
they you know i'm saying yeah yeah are
dumb that's what you're really saying
yeah yeah you're dumb you're dumb you're
an idiot i don't deserve to be here why
did you pick me you're such
you know it's like and then you can't do
your job really this book is
is because well the first thing i did
when i hooked up uh hooked up with your
book
um uh when i read your book is i scanned
through it for my name
yeah you're in there and you're in the
acknowledgment yes
that is so nice but i kind of was like
ooh which i was like that is dark
but then i just randomly i love my
husband did the same i love just
opening to things yeah just seeing you
know and um
but that's what's good about essays it's
like who's got the time just page to one
i love to just flip through
i open to page 36 this is just sort of
like a little dabbling of the sort of
emotional rollercoaster
that you're going to be going on i
opened up to first sentence i just read
was uh can i you in the butt
beautiful beautiful about a man asking
her to do this
and then by the next page i was crying
because
it's the line was for once i want to be
proud
of the way i handle things i want to
make my mom proud and i instantly
started crying
so you're going to go from highs and
lows
highs and lows we are like and it's just
you're going to get a little bit
everything with this but um gorgeous
words
i even wrote this i wrote out what do we
what do we need to accept about
ourselves where are you in terms of the
things you're like i used to be like i'm
crazy and i'm neurotic and now you're
now where you're like no that's actually
a superpower me being neurotic that's
why i'm a good mom that's why i got this
job like
honestly it's one word which you said
which is intuition like i used to
because i do again i can't i'm not
trying to go back to the childhood but
when you can't trust what's going on
around you you're like i have
no intuition so i think it was like i
don't trust it it was
did not it was dismissed and maybe i'm
seeing this wrong like i
you don't want your parents reacting
that way so you're like am i i think i'm
wrong when i'm
no you have to as a child you have to
you have to it's too emotionally
um distressful yeah for your parents to
be wrong
yeah you know so you have to enter into
their reality because that's what's
going to make me safe
also like you know it's so interesting
to me even as an adult
if you're having an inner child reaction
if it's hysterical historical
like i learn you're allowed to remove
yourself from a situation
and just go like i my gut is telling me
no
i don't owe you an ex explanation why at
the moment
and then leave and then fit and figure
it out yeah you know yeah
like we don't have to apologize for all
of the like incredible
survival tools that we
developed as children yeah but also
serve us in certain ways yeah
you know it's like i'm always
apologizing for the this ways and it's
like no that's how i grew up that's why
that is
yeah it got me far in certain other ways
and i can like honor that and find
but i just feel like i'm so seeking in
every single way and now i'm like you
know what on quite honestly if i
meditate for 10 minutes a day and i'm
not trying to get at those two 20-minute
sessions i can't do that
but i just feel like oh i can trust a
bit more where i'm coming from it's not
always right but i'm just like i don't
have time to ask
everyone to weigh in on every
thing and quite frankly like
i can do the things i thought i couldn't
do it's fine yeah
and also do i think so much more
self-reliant
something helps me emotionally what do
we say yesterday
uh grace we were um a big tool for me
and this is actually in
the uh barry michaels phil stutz book
called the tools
um which there's some like shocky parts
like if you've
if you know a lot about this there's
some parts really good okay but um
one of the tools is it's like the
deathbed exercise where when you're
spending a lot of time and energy on
something like a person
a weird situation like whatever you just
go like
am i gonna be on my deathbed going yeah
i'm really glad
i obsessed over that weird email from
that person i
sort of don't like i i like like did i
really want to spend five days of
anxiety
and perseverating in my head because
someone made me feel insecure it's just
like
like no and then you're like okay i've
pulled back that's insane
i just have to go like is this worth my
life
especially with the pandemic right we're
all like we could die at any minute like
is this emotional
reaction investing in this thing this
person is my friend why am i spending
all this time writing an email to this
person you know what i mean yeah
because they just yeah when in doubt do
nothing don't just do something sit
there that's a big thing
totally so here what are the things we
do not have to change
being emotional especially from the
region you are from we are virginia
sisters
yeah uh the region you are from being
emotional i used to think like i'm just
too loud everyone's telling me i'm too
loud
dude we survived our ancestors survived
like how about honoring the women that
came before us yeah and how being loud
and emotional
saved their lives every day yeah you
know they had to literally like
and i'm italian like my mom would just
throw a chair at my dad's head and
nobody would look up it's like
anger men are so bad and i'm like
more women should have thrown chairs at
men like isn't it that bad
i just anger to me doesn't serve like my
husband's like
it makes him very triggered if
everything isn't like going well and
normal
but to me i'm like when people are angry
it's fine like
here's the thing if you're okay it's so
amazing that you're so
self-aware and go i do this and i do
this but we cannot
wait i think we have to explore like our
ancestral
lineage and go okay some of these are
superpowers that kept
my uh ancestors alive they were i mean
virginia anywhere in those regions like
women had to fight off bears like with
their personalities
you know what i mean like with their
like we had to you had to
like i thought to find out bears with
their personality
like if we were right we're not really
sure we're not really designed to be
like dealing with another sane person
where there's a law
where if we kill each other we go to
jail you know what i mean this is very
recent that we're all like in buildings
with security our brains have not
caught up to these stimuli you know so
it is anger although like to take it out
on someone unnecessarily we can talk
about that
i'm not talking about i'm just talking
about like bursts of anger and then
moving through them i'm just like that's
how i grew up i don't find it so
shocking and
and it means like the worst about
someone i'm just kind of like
obviously appropriately in place not
like destroying someone viscerally with
your words as i used to do to your
friends
um of course but i'm just like not so
caught up with like everything has to be
like a little anger means and then to me
it's like if i'm emotional whatever
you're either i'm sorry
you with me or you don't this is
who i am like to me when i have an
emotional outburst now or when i really
want to i'm like okay
i try to parent my inner child instead
of going like i need to go to
the problem with the solution and the
person that
that made me angry or said that thing
like probably
did not mean it like i don't you know
like a lot of people like you just hurt
me all the time by accident
i mean a weird look or i didn't do that
and i'm just like in so much pain and
i'm like
you know uh georgia my therapists always
say like
you obsess over what people are thinking
about you and doing to you
um and they're not thinking about it at
all dude i mean they were like oh it's
good to see her
i mean i'm like they just you know so i
used to be and sometimes i would make
these apologies after a night with
someone and i would come off insane
because people are like sorry what yeah
i'm like and i said this and i did that
and and i took that
and they're like they're not even they
haven't even given it another thought
and it's sort of sad and it's so weird
because you
i'm not even bullshitting you you're one
of my
top five favorite people i mean true no
it's not nice it's not it's not it's
just true um
and uh it's just a fact you know and i
l when i whenever i would see you like
apologize or anything i'd be like oh my
god
it's just like she doesn't understand
that her worst what she thinks has heard
her worst
is still the best for everyone else
you know yeah if that makes any sense
yeah yeah yeah
um so i think that yeah i just am over
the
you're crazy you're neurotic it's like
no i am hyper vigilant
uh that's how my ancestors stayed alive
that is going to come in really handy
when we have children that could die at
any moment
like stop trying to dim my superpowers
like we need to take responsibility for
our reactions but
totally you know i see all my friends
spending all this money
and time in therapy like trying to be
less emotional less neurotic and less
organizy and it's just like
i have a new way of mending things with
people that does not
include speaking to them about it which
is simply i just say
and again kooky but i'm like okay i'm
gonna just ask for my higher self to
connect with their higher self
and let them work it out because it's
also literally next time i see them it's
like
things didn't even it's it's weird the
minute i just sort of send an energy of
like okay i'm going to connect with them
and kind of take out our like lower
selves
uh it is weird that person will
call me some
energy will shift like if my husband and
i are in a fight or something
i'm basically i can maybe it's lazy i'm
just like them yeah
going to the problem to the solution
like more of a spiritual just kind of
like let them work it out next thing you
know he's calling he's like let's go to
dinner it's also
it's forgiveness yeah we forgive others
not because they deserve forgiveness
because
you know and lower myself
their ancestor i'm not that's my new
thing with anyone i would
start at guilty until proven innocent
yes
like i'm at war i had to get a tattoo on
my arm that says i love you so i would
do walking meditations
where i would just it's yeah it's white
it's white it's white yeah
you don't want them to know you no no no
no no honestly um i have to withhold
love to control people
we can't change everything yeah yeah
that no that worked uh very well for me
um as you can tell
single at 38. um so yeah so other people
i realize that this is a big allen on
thing when you realize like
a lot of your pro that was my thing with
the pandemic like i was actually really
happy during the
pandemic not with the people dying and
all that stuff and friends
parents were nightmares but i was like
oh wait i'm not as sick as i thought
like
if i just don't have to see anyone i'm
good
yeah yeah other people that are the
problem i enter into that alchemy yeah
yeah and then i went into alan and
basically i was like i'm here because
everybody else is crazy
you're crazy you're crazy everyone in my
life is crazy and then you go and i'm
not
and what's the common denominator in all
these relationships dum-dum
like if you think everybody's
like maybe you're the
and maybe you have two high expectations
maybe you're entrenching with people
maybe you're grabbing perfectionism of
wanting everyone to have this
this high you're also actively seeking
sick people that recreate
the shame and the adrenaline of your
childhood circumstance so i go in and
they're like hey like
good news bad news uh you have a lot of
sick people in your life but what's
going on with you
that you keep calling them back and
you're like but i'd like to talk about
them no no no no but they
are the problem let me just get into the
the high you get from blame
that's what's beautiful about al anon
again i know i need it but like
oh no anyone you can also it's free
medicine like
because i think a lot of people aren't
like my therapist said my therapist said
it's like okay most people don't have
time to go to therapists
or the money yeah well yeah uh i'm
coming to you because i have stress
uh and this costs 200 so i'm now more
stressed out
you know yeah totally it takes forever
to find one that like matches and vibes
with you
whatever and um when there's seven
meetings a day
on anything n-a-a-a go to any any of
them you're going to hear
so much wisdom i mean i'm heavily
entrenched in oa
like there's all just great you know
because i was like i need an a
i don't know what letter is going to be
in front of it but i need an a
and totally i i don't even know what's
gonna say but i agree yeah there's
in that like take me like leave the rest
just hearing people
release what all it is it's a shame
release you know because if we don't
release our shame
it's going to crystallize and uh be
sublimated into something else
you know and you get to just reveal your
sickest because you're not
responsible for your first thought you
know yeah which is like
we grew up and we that's my parents
that's just our like trigger but we
are responsible for our first action you
know so it's just sort of like
when we do things that then make when we
act out or do something we're not proud
of it hurts us
because we carry around the
embarrassment the shame yeah i always am
just
literally if i can just pause one second
before i take an action my thing is like
thought goes to action like it's
so and it's aggressive and everybody
needs to know how much
idiot right now but even if this email
is all crazy and spelled it's like it's
no no no no no email should be more than
two sentences
yeah restraint of pen and tongue it took
me so long
because when you send that email you're
uh doing a negative contribution to your
future self because then you're waiting
around for the response
like you've like cc 10 people it's
ridiculous not ideal
well my whole thing is something
uh small will happen but i'm gonna make
it big
yeah jimmy yeah when i feels big but if
i can just say please don't
write back to this email for 20 minutes
even that 20 minutes i can be like
oh my god i can't believe i was gonna
like ream this person out
i have written on my computer my other
one opposed to no feelings aren't facts
yeah you know they might and they tend
to pass very quickly actually and if
they don't
then address it my thing is wait three
days your trauma response usually takes
three days to get the cortisol and to
get your frontal lobe reactivated
so if in three days i still feel this
way i i
probably need to either set a boundary
disengage or look dress it or whatever
you know what i mean but i'll let you
know in three days yeah because right
now my inner child is just like
ah yeah you know yeah what they say in
program is i'm good news bad news the
war is over
yeah uh bad news is you lost yeah
yeah so just like instead of figuring
out like what happened that just like
move forward and move like we're kind of
like those um uh remember that japanese
soldier in world war ii
who went into a cave to hide from the
war and they found him 40 years later
and he was like still thought
i know harper but that's what we do
we're kind of still shadow boxing
like that threat is not yeah no one's
fighting you no one's mad at you people
the the proof overwhelmingly is that
people love you and want to support you
some might be jealous of you but like
we're out of the woods for the most part
we now take a break from two
charming gals who yeah
myself and casey wilson oh right but now
we're gonna take a break
and we invited one more charming anxious
gal
who got a blowout today for these ad
reads i did not
but what happened i shower you look like
a beachy mermaid oh thank you so much
welcome i started just in time to talk
about magic spoon
now i know i need to read these verbatim
because i'm i i ramble on these ads and
we're going to lose our sponsors and
we're going to lose
which is ironic because i talk about
them so much and
but i need to start to stick to the copy
because i've made some false claims
about the products efficacy um a couple
not this product
but other because i do believe that
magic spoon you know i'm obsessed with
magic spoons i eat it like three times a
day between meals and usually
at midnight right after i have my um
tantrum my nightly tantrum oh
yeah and after we put her to bed and
between night tears uh
zero grams of sugar this is i wish this
existed when i was younger because i
destroyed
my body eating so much sugary cereal and
only four net grams of carbs in each
serving
only 140 calories a serving it's keto
friendly gluten-free grain why do you
have a ladies
i that's this is not how you talk in
real life yes when emily answers the
phone she'll be talking she's like you
need to do this and she picks up the
phone she's like hi this is emily
sorry it's keto friendly gluten free
grain free soy free low carb and gmo
free
there's a new flavor called birthday
cake yeah
no one told me about this we've got an
ex we've got exciting news magic spoon
has released a super delicious new
flavor birthday cake
birthday cake magic spoon will be
available in a special five pack for a
limited time only so get it while you
can
if you guys don't get me this everyone
is fired or build your own box
available flavors i don't how come i
don't have these custom flavors custom
bundle or cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter and
cinnamon i'm obsessed with fruity
loops because i used to have the other
kind of because she's loopy and freaky
shall remain nameless but this is a
candle called fruity loops it's my i'm
obsessed with that
i sometimes even mix it with bran flakes
you know when i need to
get the show on there with other magic
spoon because i'm a good
podcaster if you're listening from
canada a
magic spoon now ships there as well go
to magicspoon.com
whitney to grab the new limited edition
birthday cake or a custom bundle of
cereal to try it today
and be sure to use our promo code
whitney at checkout to save five dollars
off your order this offer is now good
anywhere in the u.s
or canada but only when you use our code
at checkout
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's back without a hundred
percent
and we didn't get a hernia in this room
i just say it
i just now i can't i feel like you have
carpal tunnel of the jaw
like you you're going so okay but i also
was just thinking this is the birthday
cake
is amazing because uh this way you don't
have to eat actual birthday cake in your
car every morning
which i did for about four years
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
whitney and use the code whitney to save
five dollars off thank you magic spoon
for sponsoring this episode
talking to casey wilson in this episode
as you can as you see we've
we talked a lot about the therapy we've
been to all of the magicians and healers
and psychics and
uh random just drunks we paid by check
uh to pretend they were fixing our
childhood in our 20s
we we were talking about how just go to
a professional
licensed therapist but i don't have time
and i don't
i don't want to have to leave my house
to go to a therapist and stress me out
more i i hear you i hear your inner
monologue right now saying whitney we
don't have time
right to drive to a therapist we have
real lives we're not
in hollywood running from uh you know
dead baby blood facial to dead baby
blood facial
that's a good one okay i've got i've got
great news for you
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist and you don't
have to leave
your house because here's the thing we
talk a lot about on this show don't go
to the problem for the solution and i
was like what does that mean
my boyfriend i'm my boyfriend's acting
crazy i'm gonna go to him to talk about
him acting crazy no thanks no thanks
my friend is texting her ex don't go to
her go to someone else to deal with that
stay on your lane
your girlfriend's texting your ex you
want to go fight with both
no you got to go to someone else because
they they if they're the problem they're
not going to have the solution
they created this mess go to someone who
knows what they're doing he's going to
listen to you and he's not going to
trigger you
and um piss off your inner child uh and
you can do that with better hate
better help it's way more affordable
than traditional office counseling and
financial aid is available
awesome visit betterhelp.com whitney
that's better h-e-l-p
and join the over a million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and good for you listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
whitney b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com whitney stop banging your head
against a wall
i was wildly jealous of you in the
beginning no way i swear
like i want to admit that no because you
were just everyone like liked you and i
was like
because i couldn't do improv like that
wasn't my thing and you also i hate
improv but that's another thing i pushed
through being like i should like this
and then one day jake johnson called me
and he's like we hate this
let's quit and i'm like quit we have
nothing else we made a herald team he
goes let's quit together i go
okay and it was like the first time i've
ever released something that i hate
and then but we'd feel sick before we'd
go on yeah and we're like this is cheesy
and then what what but you got so much
out of it you're so good at improvising
and
okay that's the truth like i i was like
i think this road is it's a road that
leads to nowhere ultimately
and i'm good like sometimes it's like
okay i did that and i just couldn't
believe the notion that he would come up
with to quit
something uh-huh yeah like like we need
to channel the confidence of straight
white men who are just like i don't want
to do this i'm not going to do it it's
like
yeah i'm like i'm sorry what i only do
things i don't want to do i didn't
realize that was an option
i thought i was going to take this into
the ground to the grave like and
he just said let's do it i said okay i
oh
amazing i could never do improv it took
me i had shame about it until like
this year when i realized i'm bad at it
i'm not and then i was like no no my
problem with doing
improv which is where you just comedians
get up and
say stuff on the flying on the spot it's
like a word from an audience an audience
so that's okay
they say yeah trash can and we're like
you know whatever
i'm like trash can i felt a fester in
japan
so my thing is like we'd be doing it and
we'd be just like trash can now we're
taking the trash out and we're doing
this thing and i'm like
and i would always be like you know this
would be so much better if we just
wrote down what we were going to do
first right and then
just said it you know what i mean like
why don't we just i was always like
i don't have these references i'm not
smart enough i don't know what they're
going to be talking about and it's
always white guys and
certain so they're pulling from a
certain amount of references that
oftentimes women and people of color we
don't have those cultural touch points
and
the like very weighted the name of the
hot girl from weird science like i don't
know her name
like i don't know who that you know yes
you're exactly right it's all there
it's like we have to get into their
collective like past to improv and i was
just like i don't know
i know but and i'm gonna look stupid and
i'm just like uh
like everything just goes to toriyama's
to atlanta's morrison's and like indigo
girls
i'm your girlfriend yeah and then i felt
like
every time and it's still funny to me
like i've obviously done the roast like
i whatever i can like take a joke but
like
it always i always was improvised as
like the or the hooker
or this you know what i mean it was just
sort of like so based they're like we're
gonna assign you the archetypes in two
seconds you're like oh this is how
people really think
yeah totally yeah yeah first flirt you
didn't yeah you didn't think this
through at all that was your first
like old lady fat old lady go 100 and be
like
hey grandma and i'm like you
or be like grandma like hey uh hey you
have any girls for me
like i'm the running the whorehouse why
i couldn't just be a
why did i have to what about a young
it's so unfair and marginalized
i'm good um how about saying sorry where
are you on that i'm
i still it's such a tick but i don't
necessarily like mean it as much but i
haven't
had a like i'm not great at stopping it
from happening
but i've definitely gotten a little
better on it
my not amazing i have this thing about
it where i f the reason i had to stop
like sometimes codependent behaviors
where you're trying to please other
people the only way to stop them is to
realize that you're not pleasing them
when someone says sorry all the time
it's annoying yeah i know and
i've been told it's annoying especially
by our makeup artist oh my god the best
every time i say it she's like stop
saying that
or like we both now have a tick that's
impossible now it's like sorry it's like
what did you do wrong but sometimes i'll
say it when you do something wrong i
need to know about literally if i was to
go like this and move this couple be
like sorry
and then it's a 10 and then you're so
what you're saying is
i know you're a neurotic who
doesn't want me to move
yeah i know you think i'm ruining the
podcast yeah do you know what i mean
like and i'm such a
you're such a control freak that you
would be upset by this well clearly
you don't care about disarray i am so
far off the grid in terms of giving a
at this point i
told our makeup artist said now i watch
the podcast make sure there's no in
front of you
because she wants people to see the
makeup i do well i did move
the uh microphone so we can see you're
always helpful
um but my thing yeah i know i try to
stack things in front of the guests so
that they can't be seen right and she
was basically like don't let her build
things up against i like to over
accommodate people because being in this
uh in anyone's business not just
hollywood like you just you go to a
place every day that is just like not
warm or cozy i like to just have all my
out and live the way that i live
and i don't think it's crazy this works
for me am i never oh i
knew my house i don't think it's i don't
mind it no but i just think everyone
should just claim their space
and i can't do my best work for you
unless i get to have my
you know my little pony mug and my six
coffees and my
like this is what i need to show up for
you yeah a lot of us like
june is very good at this a one june ray
field she is good at going like
you hired me i know this might look
crazy to ask you all these questions or
need all this stuff but
i can't deliver i can't do my job well
she is wonderful that i used to show up
at auditions and i would see her and
whereas i'm like a mess in my car like
just frantic crazy
she would be just sitting in the
audition room on the floor with all her
products out
just doing doing her makeup knowing who
sees like
why do i need to keep this it's like we
know what we're doing we're going in we
know where
you guys all did this in your car in the
hot sun
yeah you went to dry bar this morning
like we're all
all doing this yeah and i love that
because i used to go into audition rooms
and just
try to make everyone all the actresses
there feel
better about themselves and like that
would expend so much energy this
happened at snl too when
um abby elliott came on after me i
spent so much energy wanting her to feel
comfortable because i wish someone had
done that to me so i'm taking her out
i'm
and then really then comically i'm let
go and she's
good you know because i'm like why don't
you spend a little bit of energy on
yourself
so the being too loud thing yeah have
people told you you're loud
yes yes and it's my son is very loud
to a level that first conference they're
like he's too loud and
we can hear him from every room of the
preschool and so occasionally i will bow
to that if we're out you know when he's
loud
but henry's great i can find him uh at
carnivals wonderful
my husband and i are like we started
feeling so bad always being like can you
lower your voice because i'm like this
is part of he is just
a boisterous spirit we're already saving
up for his rehab and
he is it's just who he is and also like
yeah he had to be loud me and
me and my husband are yelling all the
time
he adapts we're screaming at our older
son so he is like i'm the second
he's the second one he's like how does
how do teachers not understand the
birth order thing
the young obvious the youngest is always
the loudest and the most
because they have or that uh they have
to fit into uh
an already existing paradigm paradigm
and like
they have to adapt and also
i'm just this is a generalization moms
don't freak out by the time you have
your second
kid you kind of like know he's not gonna
die every five seconds
your first kid you're like poor kid no
yeah it's like oh you're fine
you're good put some water on it i don't
know where he is yeah but then i hear
him
he's probably just like alerting me that
like come find me
like i'm three and i'm hanging upside
down on a jungle junction site with no
shoes on
being loud is um i don't know i i know i
i
don't yell into microphones anymore the
way that i did and by the way i'm also
losing my voice so
you know don't be that it seems you are
still being a bit loud yeah yeah i mean
i grew up at a time where like
i had to fight for attention i'm in a
male dominated business where it's like
if i don't
do this no way they won't listen
you know i grew up in this business a
time where like i had to be scary
see i i do i don't think i could do
stand-up because i
i you're so amazing that you can exist
in that because obviously hollywood is
male dominated but that's another realm
of
male dominated and you've done such a
beautiful job like forging great
connections with people and being
respected
and as you should thank you but but it
was so intimidating to me
and my thing has always been like i
didn't have the skill set but still
like like i was like oh that no you
would be so good at stand up i'm not
going to
force you but on your you travel with
your podcast
and you do uh do the podcast which is
like well
danielle and i make people listen to us
sing and dance something that brought
your live
show to you yeah and we're like okay so
you will pay to see me sing actually
broadway said you will see us i do love
it
like okay when people get famous at
something
and they were like well this is the
thing i really want to do and it's like
comedian please stop being so serious
nobody wants it
yeah do your comedy yeah like what are
we doing um as i'm like let's talk about
our childhoods and cry together
but i um like when michael jordan was
like i'm gonna play baseball everyone's
like no one wants that from you
we don't need jared leto's like i have a
band we're like no what
like i think it's good from what i but
but when people get in
and they then do something else yeah
it's like yeah i'm a family that's what
the
girl you tricked me i came to your
uh donut store and now you're trying to
sell me like no no no like now at least
we are singing about the content on our
product no
but at least we try to relate no but
unhappy you're an amazing singer you
were uh uh the megan mulally episode
on happy endings was so amazing and
funny i also think if you have an extra
talent that is funny
you work it into your main talent i'm
not saying i'm just like when you're
like i'm super famous now come watch me
play guitar and like
when billy joel started doing classical
music it's like buddy
buddy buddy and i i also
uh cannot stand it i know he's alive a
lot of them wanna i didn't know i
literally had to think about it i was
like you don't don't care no real estate
for that frankly
um one thing about podcasting it's
really helped me
just be able to say i don't know yeah i
could never admit i didn't know
something
before a podcast i'd like make something
up yeah totally i'd be giving like wrong
advice i'd be like oh yeah what's that
no what's the guys don't know i know
because i just
and now i'm just like i don't know
someone would be like have you seen that
show
i had not seen it i couldn't say no
because
but that was almost like wanting to like
have commonality
not even seem smart just be like yeah
and then whatever they would say about a
show i have not seen i'd be like yes
and i was yep yep haven't seen it it's
gonna be
they care if i say oh i haven't
seen it i just tricked you into bonding
with me and now
i'm luring you into a boring
conversation where i just say and now
you
i've quickly understood i've never seen
that which is the irony my dad used to
always say this
um and i never kind of understood until
much later
like this person's dream is that you
haven't seen it and they get to tell you
all about it
never once thought of that you're taking
away their ability
to dazzle you so zip it beside it you
know what i mean yeah yeah
well don't do that either yeah i know
but yeah when you're like i think i'm
like everyone's dream conversation
because i haven't seen
anything and i'm like no i've never seen
breaking bad whatever's like oh dude let
me tell you all about it
and then they get to be the start i just
get to sit there and listen i don't have
to do any work
yeah that's right i know the fans are
like uh like you ever listen my
name
how do you feel about okay the skill of
being able to be crazy as a woman has
saved my life many times
being crazy loud reactive like we walk
down dark streets at night and
to me the crazier i do believe there's
um something in the 48 laws of power
i think about seeming more crazy than
you are
so people think twice about with
you yes yes you know
yeah so it's like we spent all this time
we're like do you want to see this
i don't mean crazy like abusive or mean
or physical that's something i'm talking
about you know
but there's like if i walk onto a set
and i feel like a bunch of guys that
might not respect me or everyone seems
like she doesn't deserve to be here
which i'll find those are all fine
emotional emotions to have
yeah but just something like hey can i
just get an edible arrangement for lunch
thanks just something just crazy right
whatever like just something insane like
hey can i get those 12 cupcakes to eat
in my car for my lunch thank you
like and i'm gonna roll the seat down
just knock on my door when you're ready
yeah
like just something if i'm in charge
then they're like okay this person is
not to be with she's not well
she's not well but she's willing to ask
for something
that is socially deemed weird yeah with
no shame at all yeah yeah
you know what i mean yeah like we're not
gonna pull one over on this one
[Laughter]
okay so what let's talk about what we
what we still
want to change about ourselves because
we're in radical i'm radically an
acceptance of most of the things that
i've tried to change for so long
a new thing that i want to change is my
own perception of like my mothering
is like there's just so much guilt there
and i know this is boring and
and we've heard it but it is really hard
to just get out it's there for a reason
that conversation because
you know we i work a ton and i have to
get out of that narrative like my kids
are fine like in reality what i'm seeing
is they're happy kids
and i'm sure and also it's okay they're
gonna be in therapy about me like i'm
trying to negotiate every little moment
with them
or not just i told my therapist i'm like
i'm gonna be honest with you i will no
longer be talking about my past she's
like why are you here
i'm like because i'm done talking about
it i actually want to talk about what's
joyful in my life it activates and
energizes me so much more than
just like
bitching about this person and that and
what already happened it's like yeah we
know that story we're done
okay also um the more you tell a story
the more
so our memories are imperfect good news
bad news uh
moran surf uh does amazing work on this
uh a neuroscientist at i can't remember
the
oh he said no he's at northwestern now
and um
about and this isn't about like sexual
assault survivors and all that kind of
stuff that's not what i'm talking about
but
it's usually something that wasn't that
traumatic like usually we remember
something to be worse than it was
or less uh bad than it was so
if it's really really traumatic to cope
you know what i mean you kind of like
so many my friends myself included that
had like you know weird sexual in
their childhood like what do you mean no
it's fine
it was winning me and then you don't
categorize it even like that because it
was too painful
you had to get the new truth of like and
disassociate
you know or whatever so now you're kind
of like what do you mean and then you're
like oh yeah that was bad yeah i'll be
telling someone a story they're like ooh
and i'm like no it was good let me as i
yeah as you get older and your psyche is
able to cope with it you're able to go
like that was not okay
yeah and whatever and i i minimized it
and i really should
uh deal with how wrong that was but then
sometimes we
um are historic about things because
when we tell a story
we're wired to uh keep
uh uh basically punching up the story
based on what people react to
because you're getting like then you're
like remembering it yeah like i'll
i'm like stop telling the story because
every time you tell it
what happened to me was worse the more
like i can say like a meter maid gave me
a ticket
by the time i tell it four times i'm
like she came at me with a knife
yeah that woman yeah you know what i
mean like she was in a clown suit
it's just like insanely yeah yeah yeah
yeah so i have to watch myself with that
because i have this people pleasing need
to make stories more interesting than
they are
it's like or you are a comedian too i
mean it's like i talk about in the book
like if you're going to tell a story
give me something
like a certain point i do want people to
jazz things up a little more but you
have this
amazing ability with your writing to
make something that should just be like
prosaic or simple like so
engaging you know um and so i love that
about you that's not like exaggerating
it's just like let me take you on this
journey of these things
in a way yeah that is like okay what
else
i just wrote down you don't get to have
low self-esteem anymore
oh that's a challenge i guess yeah that
is a challenge you've issued me yeah
i turned 40 during the pandemic and i
have to say something truly shifted and
i've heard women say that and
and and and some other things have
shifted into like aging stuff i never
i just wasn't a person that was always
like i'm aging like i did not
i really didn't take what was the moment
because because
there's a moment when you see something
in a mirror
or whatever where you're like the
yeah like my eyes has always been a
thing because my mom got an eye lift and
i'm always like i just started like
only seeing that and but before i really
just didn't take it i was like i don't
have the energy or time to take
on it is what it is like obviously i
always wanted to look good but not
and by the way many people have paid me
a lot of money to be the lead of shows
so it can't be a lot most people like it
you know it's like sort of like the data
says this isn't you know
totally and but i also the flip of it
has been like i really just i
for the first time i'm like i don't
really care what people think i'll talk
openly about money i've spent or things
it's like i work i have a job i'm taking
money from anyone and
i've been extremely lucky and privileged
but i'm also just not gonna
apologize for just what i have and yeah
it's just
gravity yeah it never happens you know
yeah
so so that's like it's been giving me
permission to be like oh i'm in the back
half of my life and for whatever reason
30s was like is it okay to have all this
is it okay to be this happy in my
marriage and with my kids
yes yeah it just so i also think you and
i
have uh worked so hard on like like
boundaries like setting boundaries
is so hard to do which ones have you
said in your life or like what
they're usually for ourself right yeah
yeah
new boundaries it's so hard i'm trying
this is seems like a parenting tip but
like i'm trying to step banners around
my phone with my kids
and just like trying to be with them
it's so hard because little kids are
boring sometimes and like it's hard like
i was an interesting kid you were tap
dancing at four yeah
like give me something to look alive but
i think i'm also trying to set
boundaries with people asking so many
favors to me and i know i've asked you a
million
but like no no i was so proud of you i
mean we rescheduled this no less than 16
times
we are i was so proud of you i was like
yes rescheduled
take care of yourself like i love this
yeah and stuff stuff like that of just
like it's okay and and saying no to just
insane requests
because and i hate to bring oprah into
this but i don't hate it because her
thing is like when you say yes to
someone your brain
says great then that favor is done nope
and i they'll take that and that's
i want to extend this kindness it's like
i'll look back through emails when you
say yes to someone you don't know and
there's only f there's
50 more yes yes but if you it's not
energetically right the first time just
say no
negative uh contribution to your future
self yes
like trying to stuff like that obviously
it's a friend i want
to do things like but you know when you
want to do something uh i want to talk
can i talk about your mom or no yeah and
sort of you know because to me it's like
i'm
all about like like appreciating the
coping mechanisms that we the ancestral
sort of trauma we inherited
like what was her like italian italian
and my mom's dad was in the navy so they
moved like 14 times
when she was growing up and her mom
didn't drive so she'd have to just like
get to school and try to find someone to
give her a ride
that to me like is my mom so she
developed this personality that people
would want to give her a ride home yeah
and she could never have people over to
her house so she was just like having to
like
always be a big personality then she
became this huge feminist and kind of a
feminist leader
um trying to get women elected and so
she had this you know
big personality and but was like doing
every pta thing and doing every single
thing
and was so funny and great but she also
developed a ritalin addiction
which i didn't find out about until like
10 years after died
really yeah it's well yeah
i'm like my mouth is really dry i just
need some water i can't speak
but you know it wasn't being prescribed
in the right way for her and
the sad part is is my dad was like
scared to tell me and i'm like i so
don't care
like she didn't have access or the money
for the things
to do the nuts cooking woman i
just told you guys about like
it was just wasn't the time and therapy
wasn't available to her
financially and whatever and really it's
just sad and this is my mom trying to do
it all
that is what happened there so that is
just so important to hear because
we have to remember that our kids
have the information to look back and
think
that way yeah so all the things you
think are your mistakes now in parenting
they're gonna look back and go
yeah my mom of course she did that
that's what you had to do at the time
workaholism work
twice as hard to get half as much
working two jobs how are you gonna
they will forgive you they will forgive
you the way that you look back on that
and you're like what choice did she have
and i'm actually like it's i don't find
it to be that huge part of her story
like i also hate when people reduce
someone's life to addiction it's like
yeah that's a part of their story but
people are so much
get more interested in why they
started using the substance in the first
place that's way what was the problem
they were trying to solve
emotionally because they couldn't you
know why do they look for
external things to meet their emotional
needs what was not available to them
it just wasn't available yeah if that a
woman in that time doing
you know uh march feminist marches and
working and having kids like that was
probably a solution for a lot of women
48 states with her before i was three
and you know she's trying to get the
equal rights amendment passed and it
didn't happen and there's sorrow and
there she so worked her ass off
yeah and you know again that's how i
have my work ethic but it doesn't come
when you're doing all of that it there
it does come at a cost if you don't have
the emotional
things in place or the infrastructure to
like get help and then i want to ask you
two questions
uh that uh what you think your mom would
say
about my version of feminism
in a couple things is it uh is it a
backward is it backwards or is it wildly
feminist because sometimes when i hear
something i'm like
wait a second so i just feel like right
now there's this thing where
all women you know whether it's an
over-correction or whether it's just
like
because we finally have those
opportunities now or whatever not
everyone it's still
you know but um i see a lot of women
that feel like they have to be like
ceos or f like be a founder of a
company at 22. you know what i mean
there's all this pressure
and i think for me like the goal isn't
that you're all
running company if you want to that's
great yeah
but if you want to like have a flower
shop or be you know i mean that sounds
great you should be able to do that too
because i used to go like what are you
doing we need to turn this flower shop
into an app and then my new thing is
some things just live in this current
space everyone's like your podcast
should be a tv show in the tv show and
i'm like it's a podcast
it's that's what it is and also your
lives
if i have to see another horrible tv
show that was based on a successful
podcast it was canceled after yeah
because it was supposed to be a podcast
it wasn't supposed to be a movie or tv
show not everything has to be every
extension of it
because i just feel like we're a little
bit in this like overachiever mode where
we all have to be like
you know so well my mom actually like
after she was so disappointed with what
had ended up happening she became a
preschool director and she's like this
is what i love doing
exactly working with kids and it was a
much smaller life in
a good way i have a sick thing where
i'll like meet a teacher and i'm just
like they don't get paid enough
and they're like you know our future and
blah blah and then i'm like well do you
want to come on my podcast and then we
can start like a teacher podcast where
you like
zoom with like i have to go to that i
have time we're branding you
i have to make a business out of every
person i meet
and they're just like no no i i like
what i do yeah i want
and that's your act and i'm like no no
no you don't no you don't thought about
what i might be like i don't believe
women
mm-hmm i'm like no you don't trust me
trust me yeah and it's just
you know so my version of feminism is
like i'll get you to my level of
talk semi-happiness you know what you'd
be a feminist if you ruined your
relationship worked 24 hours a day
and became a toxic ceo you know what i
mean
that's so sick um okay we now
take our second break from casey wilson
much to everyone's chagrin i know
i know to talk about um
life because you know what life is emily
what is it it's a puzzle
that's deep it's really just a puzzle
you're taking the pieces putting them
together sometimes you put them in wrong
but when you get them right
sometimes they're missing that is gut
that is
the rorschach test of this you are
failing it miserably
but when you get you know that's the
feeling when you get a puzzle piece that
fits
you know it's like the it's like those
euphoric oh god it's euphoric
orgasmic when we were touring i mean
so i've heard
[Music]
um i have been buying puzzles on the
road
it's it's not really the same feeling
now that i have a phone it's not
as satisfying as it used to be right so
uh you know
you bring like a boxed puzzle on no i
bought one
in spokane at this place called boo
radley's a toy store and i
for five minutes i i couldn't do it it
was just too boring so i'm going to give
you guys give it a gift bag for one of
the guests okay great
and but i'm so best fiends which we
always talk about on the show
i have started playing on tour at
airports
in car rides ubers and i am so much less
crazy
yeah well sure it has kept me from like
texting exes and
like firing off emails i should not be
firing off because it's there's
something like soothing about it
because you're doing something yeah but
you're not like working right
does that matter i'm obsessed i can't
put it down because it's like i don't
know i think it's
helping my brain because i had like the
coveted fog i had the wheat edibles
like i think it's getting my brain like
muscled up again i can't explain it
yeah i feel like i'm sharper it's just
awesome a ton of fun puzzles lots of
levels and the things characters
the things are so cute they look like
remember a little um remember pill bugs
that would roll up roly-polies oh wait
in real life yeah
no i don't think bugs are cute those are
but these ones are
on here they're cute little blobs yeah
and they're like little pac-mans mixed
with little bugs
with little little tiny ghosts like
they're so cute they're so cute
love download the five star puzzle oh
sorry
start again download the five star rated
puzzle game best fiends today free today
on the app store or google play that's
friends without the r best fiends
whitney you're my best fiend
oh i wish i'd come back the other
thing is um i'm now
in a relationship with a lover
who we did talk about i'd call my lover
yeah
every comment is when you have to stop
this makes me cringe it is making me a
little sick
but i'm i'm so happy for him his
concubine he is my lover
and he um we talked about the last name
conversation if we get married
and i was like oh let's do the blend i
know a lot of people that are blending
their last name
because look i'm i'm all about keeping
my i i'm not trying to be a bad like
woman or
i just my last name is cummings like i
would like to change
my last name just at any anyway that's
just a personal like yeah yes
and his last name was barnes and i was
like okay what if we
combine them it's if we combine them it
would be
barn is that
the feminist choice god i want to say
you know women can't have it all but
maybe
that's not the all we want
i'm oh could we do whitney whitney
barnes comings
like my mom and his name go first
uh maybe i don't know
you like that jordan seems to shorten
both names yeah i don't have time to say
all the like what am i doing
autocorrect and then what um
what was i going to just say what did
you just say i don't know i love being
able to do this on podcast
websites just going to say yeah and then
i don't cut that out because then
everyone gets to go oh
we're allowed to forget what we said in
the middle of a conversation in front of
thousands of people and it's fine
yeah it's totally fine um but no oh
that was important
okay what would your mom think about the
fact that i recently
started loving uh gender like archaic
gender roles
oh i think she would also you know this
is interesting and this is
so my mom is a preschool director and
this mom was a ceo and she was working
crazy crazy hours and my mom pulled her
in her office and she told me this after
my mom died
and she's like i do think you're working
too much and like i think
you in in not even in a guilty way she's
like i think you'll be happier to like
pick up the kids early they're staying
so late
and i think other people would might
hear this and they're like what what
what but i think my mom was kind of like
you can let yourself off the hook too
like you don't have to
like and i i do think about that too i'm
like i could just like
keep working or i can just pick up my
kids and go sit home for a little but
here's the
thing about gender roles here's why i
say that because
pretty much all the traditional
stereotypic female gender roles
have been made super easy with like post
mates
doordash grocery delivery like i'm like
yeah yeah i'll do the cooking
i'll do the grocery buying then done
yeah yeah yeah like and all the stuff
that they're supposed to do
can't really be uh replaced with an app
so i'm sort of like this is
you know it gets tricky when both of you
are working and i'm like
why am i on set worrying about our
grocery order when you're
psychologically just skipping off on
your dippity doo dah merry day to pursue
your dreams
but i've got this like mental load of
like where are the kids right now
that's biologically that's you're wired
for that my therapist said there can
only be one foreman in a relationship
and you
being honest you wouldn't want it to not
be you it's also
when i was a kid my mom used to say god
and play come back before dark
yeah and now it's like you can't that
would be
is that even legal like that would be
like you would be arrested yeah to like
let your kids just like wandering around
the neighborhood
people if people saw kids even walking
in l.a they'd be like
just like two kids like six-year-olds
alone it would be
shocking that was my entire childhood
and she would say come back before dark
and like you don't know what i would
just go knocking up and down on doors
like want to play no
no two strangers who wants to play would
anyone want to play only strangers and i
would take my knocks i'm like great
but that's why we have like charm and
we're able to talk to anybody
like i don't know i just feel like some
adversity is good
your um book gives such wild permission
to be vulnerable and release the most
um the things you're least proud of
it what it did to me feel like reading a
diary i shouldn't be reading
yeah yeah yeah so um believe it or not i
even drew some boundaries with the book
and didn't put things in if you could
believe that you got to hold it yeah
couple of things yeah you'll realize you
said not you'll realize you're sitting
on a gold mine and make sure
season two has always gotta be better
than season one once you realize
how uh successful this is gonna be
you're like you know what i'm gonna talk
about that abortion right now
uh i think i was gonna hold sacred like
no thanks
no i'd like to retire soon um i
am going to let you read my diary
from when i was 12. okay we just found
it
am i finding a certain part or i'm just
well it's the one okay i just opened a
really great one just simply it was cold
today
wait start with this one okay april 8th
1997.
hello today was a sunny day
i had a dentist appointment yesterday
and i have
another today i have a cavity and my
teeth hurt
the grading period ended today tomorrow
i'm going to tell
i'm going to tell joe that i want to
have some we make a
start transition it's all very run-on
tomorrow i'm going to tell joe that i
need some space and some time away
from him to think i hope it turns out
good i've been going
i've been going in the not hot
how old are you i've been going in the
hot tub naked lately
and if lisa found out oh she would
crucify me who's lisa my aunt that i
lived with okay
granddad is home and better and i'm
gonna see him on friday
dad is coming in on thursday which means
in his language friday
i hope i hope that ashley and jenny
juan are doing okay they are fooling
themselves being apart
i love ashley um
two sentences back-to-back are so great
i love ashley my nightgown is lilac
and my nails are shiny powder pink yay
this is like so beautiful whitney it's
it's so
it's the one that you open up to you're
really putting no but that was the
beginning when i love that you start
with the weather just like
all rounders always i always grasp
it out it it starts to evolve into
something very
can we follow up on i d i told joe i
wanted space
i hope a resolution is found concerning
us i'm sorry
doubtful but i am hopeful only seven
more weeks of school left
i'm gonna be a sophomore next year oh my
goodness it's all so crazy to me
my connection with joe today was so
intense i can't
handle it at all we're reading romeo and
juliet in english
i'm going to start getting up at 6 a.m i
love that it's a ride
and walking in addition to my afternoon
runs
this is where yeah the toxic behavior
starts
i hope to see laura this weekend i love
her she's my girl and i miss her
tomorrow is courtney's birthday and i'm
going i'm getting her some soap
oh well she never really liked me
anyways
these are taking us on a ride i want to
go to prom i want sunny warm weather i
miss bethany
oh the agony
literally but it's like okay we all try
to change what you're saying what's the
same
and a great way like bookmarks some of
the most dark are just
open like this is just this is what a
greg should have had enough respect
for me to not let him call and one
harass
to waste my time three make me look like
an ass
ugh he sucks lisa is still letting me go
to allison krause
and so that's very cool joe wants to get
back together and he is straight
wigging yo i'm ready for bed
i do start to appropriate later in the
journal
in kind of an unsettling way okay hmm
yes today was very bad
um not good at all not even a little bit
okay mad depression i don't know what
that is
[Music]
she's like the prettiest girl like even
according to our group
um oh well nothing offensive or neg
to smash but that's like depressing to
me speaking of my love
she is coming down tomorrow yay is this
about this mythic bethany i don't know
let's go she's we she uh we are follow
each other on
instagram okay i was in love with my
best friend when i was
11. oh goodness it's already wednesday
time is zooming
[Laughter]
oh my god greg wasn't at school hmm
a lot about greg it's all good in my
head
let's go down to the mermaid page and i
will buy you a bottle of wine
this is a lyric lyric from is that
justin krause no i think it's a joni
mitchell lyric
okay oh my it was pretty today and i
cannot lie
so so so sunny sandra pissed me off in
gym
but i still love her i talked to smash i
so
wanted to see her yay smash tomorrow's
wednesday sweet
graduation is the same day as dave
matthews sucks
oh well say cheese
it's it's a i mean is it a portrait a
ride it's a portrait of a
true insanity what's this one seeing a
sad one but this one
with a dog here um
my skin looks really good these days
i laid out the past two days so i'm tan
it's
it's good for me my nails are pretty
pink i feel good
i feel nice oh yes i do school is so
close to being over
sad sad sad for me this summer is gonna
be what a nerd i was sad that school was
ending
this summer's gonna be live as hell yeah
fat tuesday is a comment
p-h-a-t and no
okay good and finally april 22nd earth
day
in full effect
my body burst kathy and i chilled in the
hot tub
were you naked then probably mad jack
reese
does ice cream tomorrow's wednesday we
had a quiz
oh my god it's very staccato it's very
staccato it's staccato whereas casey
takes you on an elegant it's not like
it's jarring
she eases you out and mr harper collins
published honestly why do we need to
work you've already written a book yeah
they're going to be like um
you do i am obsessed this is making me
awesome it's what are i don't know what
are the ones that
okay i don't know april 16th 1997 today
was beautiful it was sunny and i loved
it i'm really seeing genuinely weather
has a big effect
is i i might have my ambitions might
have been to be a weather girl and i
just wasn't
i had to stop running today because i
felt sick not good joe is seriously
wiggin
i have so many decisions in my life
right now that need to be made
ah is so crazy these days i got my
report card tomorrow
not much to say today good night dot dot
dot
oh my god i love wasn't there so much
like writing about school and teachers
and report cards
because that was like it was everything
was the end of the world
long day people were pissing me off
today oh man
i was i could read this for 20 million
yeah no i was
furious at everyone all the time i mean
i was like how
dare then you have little bursts of
positivity
um i had an okay day i shopped
dark yeah have you ever looked at your
old journal yeah i didn't
it's talking about it's not pc but i
would draw pictures of guns and bullets
going into people's heads and like
blood's pretty good
like my girlfriends i'm so mad at them
like i genuinely want to kill that have
you think in your next book putting
passages of your journal in yes i
thought about that there's just it's
it's
in every it's some dark side i was
always ranking my friends from one to
ten
yes we're wiring up we're wired to do
that like it's a it's in the tribe we
used to have to do that
because it's also like it used to be
when you were 25 you were in charge
yeah when you were 50 girls were fifth
queens at 15.
do you mean like we are wired to be you
know what i'm saying
we get it honestly yeah yeah none of
this is still the spirit is so
you which i really charms me and touches
me
i am mississippi burning on my face
i am taking tetracycline for my face
it looks changed you're like you got
your face going your face
products i love it well a lot of it is
in reaction like i said really bad acne
i was on accutane twice
oh okay which i think is like we were
talking about the other day
and it's true that's illegal now right
yeah wow yeah
yeah not ideal um so that all it was not
ideal it was like skin updates
constantly
um i talked to joseph so when i guess
when i liked him his name was joe
and when i was battled him his name was
joseph i just can't believe at that age
because you're younger than me you were
like i need some space
yeah take time like you're throwing out
boundaries there for joe i don't i need
some space at school
how are you gonna have space like where
would you get space
oh my god it's weird because i did write
as
if i feel like i wrote it as if i knew
someone would read it one day
me too i've never not written a diary
that i'm like my kids will read this my
husband
do you think or like if someone finds it
you know what i mean like i'm secretly
hoping that i'd be like this is not for
your eyes unless
and want it to be and it's just sort of
like if this like stumbles into the
hands of a literary agent
producer at some point like i just the
fact that we could never just like
honestly release our emotions
people are like oh i write in my journal
every day i'm like i'm gonna monetize
that and you're looking at it right
there
yeah who's this for what are diaries
even for
i don't know i'm talking to a person i
know everyone's like journaling is so
good for you i guess it is
i think when you have a lot of anger
that's old um there's this thing we do
in elena where you just like
write for 12 minutes and then just burn
it or throw it away
right like that because you're like no
i'm throwing away writing something out
you're
you think is a good idea to say you
realize like i cannot say that
right like that looks insane it's just
too easy to say it
but when i write it i'm like no no no
thanks no thank you
what else is going on
with your podcast are you touring not
now we're doing like
uh live shows on virtually that are
actually going great and i'm like it's
so much easier
people love sesh in a way that is
they do but i'm sure when the world
starts turning we'll have to get back on
the road but i'm kind of like i don't
leave my kids for
i mean we don't do the amount of like
dates you do but we'll get and it's like
we only have to do the show once and as
many people as well
i am such a will you please talk to me
about touring when you do it
yeah or like where like the way you can
route things in the way that you can
make your life easy you know what i mean
like
yeah cause it's like the only skill i
have at this one time we had to uber
from like boston to like florida
because we missed like things have not
never been set up yeah but that wasn't
routed
no and then we missed the first show
yeah things weren't and then i was like
it we're going to mcdonald's yeah i
ate an amount then i was crying then i
was watching leah remini's like
old reality show like things get dark
fast when it's not set up well
i end these very awkwardly i didn't just
call you a i was about to say
sesh
i know it's so hard to say a
that's fine and that
i i kind of love that it's just audio in
a way that that could be why
there's such a um i don't know there's
such a like cult
attachment to youtube yeah i don't know
why
i do you know like you work so hard on
certain things and nothing happens and
then you're kind of just like whatever
we'll try this and
somehow it's like when i did the create
anything when i was just
authentic and being myself right and i
started care
and didn't care like that's what
podcasts are showing
like these 400 people lawyers that
weighed in on how i look
you know i can't imagine why that didn't
go well
and a bunch of people taking a funny
person and going like me sitting and
having control creatively and just
having a nice time
you literally just being yourself people
are like money money money money
yeah you know what i mean it's like the
universe is trying to tell us
to just be yourselves and i'm like but i
need to pay someone to tell me to not be
my okay but
then what you're saying if at this point
then the people i have spoke to about
your podcast it is so intense they like
quote you
they're like i you know yeah well yeah
it's just funny
feel it you have to take it in i do i
guess i'm always kind of like i don't
think it's about us
it's just like there's a audience for
this because it started out about the
real housewives it's the most flimsy
framework it's really just kind of a
comedy show
but it's also just like so specific it's
like i know what i'm going to tune into
this
i'm not going to get lectured about
politics like i know what i'm coming
here yeah
and forget about the i can listen to i
don't even watch the housewives and it's
so funny
it's just as if you're gonna just wait
into the garbage and like you don't have
to know why it works because your fans
know why it works yeah i don't know
and my thing is like there's a certain
point where you have to just go like
i've never listened to one back
ever not one time that's actually okay i
think
yeah i'm just kind of like we have a
great editor and we'll cut stuff right
after then you'll start to
uh amplify things that you think are bad
i've done that before and i'm like oh my
god i've got to stop now actually
weirdly danielle will get more granular
with it i just i'm like i think it's
okay
whatever you're doing is working just
keep doing whatever again like this
isn't going on show time like
it's like in and out it's like a very
ephemeral
um yeah but i just think that like to
overthink something that's working is
like
are all like that's just in our brain
right this is one thing to do
okay this is working really well let me
fix it yeah like what
the live shows we put energy and timing
because i'm like people are paying for
this but the podcast i'm like no they're
not
yeah totally but it's also i met so many
people this weekend that listen to this
podcast and a lot of you are probably
like
uh you talk to much and you
interrupt i get it i know
i'm growing on camera in front of you
guys it's like you know what i mean it's
just sort of like i'm learning how to do
this skill
and we will receive some feedback like
someone like oh okay i heard that but
it's also everyone loves it just look at
the numbers and the whatever
it's like if they're giving feedback
they're listening i've never looked at
the numbers
i'm like i don't want to get dragged
down by this one thing in my life that's
joyful and fun
but then look at your whatever i'm glad
i'm you know making money so i'm like
all right
my new thing is that if i beat myself up
about this podcast or if
i am like this sucks i'm not good then
i'm insulting the fans yeah
because they like people are listening
and they like it yeah like who am i to
say
you know what i mean people they know
i'm just so grateful people like it yeah
just like because we couldn't trust the
motives of all the business the people
that use we used to have to
uh address you we had no idea why they
liked it that's not working all
those people weighing in not
working i i twice now
casting directors have told me i didn't
get uh jobs i should have gotten because
i reminded the producers of their
ex-wife
you even got that no surprise surprising
and then also just uh they wanted to
or whatever and i was just like
i don't know how to do this right like i
i'm shape-shifting i'm morphing i'm
trying to be what you want me to be and
you don't even know what you want me to
give you the best advice one day that
made me laugh danielle next we'll talk
about it and you were like
when i do an audition i used to go in
and give like a whole song and dance
before the lines
and you're like but it's almost setting
myself up to fail cuz like you're great
at just talking and chatting
and you're like i'm also giving away my
material for free but second like then
when you inherently read the
lines it's almost no matter what their
lines are probably shitty yeah and so
you're not going to be as funny as
necessary and they think you're a bad
actress and not funny reflects on them
but it's like no this is
your material
yeah so when you go into another they
come in with fun in life and you know
you come in with not a damn thing so
they can project on to you
because i used to come in and be like
the parking was crazy but i'm killing
i'm trying to make everybody laugh
coffee bean was packed then i read their
stuff and i'm like um hey babe
and then i'm like you need to be home
tonight don't make me wait up because
the parts for women
were just like oh you're home need
anything
and then i was just like dude i'm just
saying the main character you need to
get back out there
you need to get on a spin bike yeah yeah
yeah yeah like the roles that we get
cast for it's like doing yoga i'm like
the friend of the friend of the main
girl you know what you need to do
you need to get a makeover um and we
like have to do
that i'm like let's get some wine
tonight girl yeah girl that's a lot of
guys
i show up at the i
for the first time ever like actually
passed
on doing a self tape they're like it's
in the bag it's yours
which is always like oh my god and then
you read it and you're like so insulting
yeah this and i just didn't do it
because i was like you know what i'm
just not
some some other young actor should get
this and get famous like go with god
this would make me hate myself just
being like hey
like i just am like yeah you're like i
can't you know what i mean i'm good
yeah there's a certain point i and then
spending four days
auditioning for a job you don't have uh
why don't we get paid to audition and
pitch
i know and pitch that's my new thing is
the main thing because you're
working your eyes oh if you want four
days of my time like you just have to
pay that and then you're going to take
those ideas
and then you're going to take those
ideas when i pitch them and i'll see
them in the in the job you didn't give
me
yep pay me but when your friend used to
say you don't write one word unless
you're getting paid
oh love her so much i think that's
another just real now i wrote all that
before i got paid by going what's
still waiting on that check it comes in
installments i'm still waiting on the
last few
and i um i i just think that like know
when you have the leverage you have
that's the thing we're working so hard
for all this leverage
and now use it yeah you know what i mean
and inherently people like when you say
no
and then also the new thing the leverage
that i i it's
i'm not a hero whatever but my whole
thing is like i just i just want to be
the person that i wish existed when i
was younger
and then i also go you know what i i i'm
not going to do
no more favors i'm done with favors it's
enough
um and when you're doing something in
favor you're not really cause you show
up and you're annoyed you don't want to
be there like just don't you're not
helping them
because you then it ruins your
relationship like how will i feel on
that day
when i'm up at and whenever when
i'm there on set i know no one the
energy's bad you're not you know
it's like when you agree to drive
someone to the airport in three months
you're like great and that's a great
idea and you get there and you're like
oh my god i have to get up at 3 15
a.m like when you're scheduling a bunch
of girlfriends to do a dance to single
ladies here's the thing got a good idea
by the way we should still look together
val renewable
renewal renewal and uh
yeah last thing i'm going to say because
i'm just so impressed i mean i i'm
totally serious when i said every time
you were like
can't do this can't do this can we do
this like when we were rescheduling i
was like
thank you for doing this because then
you're rescheduling and
because then you would have showed up
resentful and annoying and like a lot
like
couldn't be happier to be here yes it's
like you can't so
that to me was going like oh the fact
that she's rescheduling means she cares
about our friendship and cares about
showing up
as the best version of herself and like
thank you for that thank you for that
so happy to be here i'm so proud of you
i i just
love you you're so wonderful and you
give so much like great spirit
oh my god i love you guys don't write
elephants casey wilson find her on
instagram because she's really decided
to lean into uh instagram
she's gonna do it she thought she was
above it for a while 10 years too late
now she's fully like hey guys
it is the best you have to do more
instagram stories
bully her into doing it okay you're a
gift thank you i love you
i love you casey wilson all right
elephants
[Music]
ah
[Applause]